ينضموا الينا من مونتانا مايكل نائب مساعد
وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق ينضم الينا
الينا ايضا من موسكو انوفا المحلل السياسي
والاستراتيجي ابدا معك سيد مايكل في
مونتانا ما الذي استدعى اليوم هذا التصريح
من القول بان
الولايات المتحده تحرص على الا تستخدم هذه
المساعدات الغربيه لاوكرانيا في ضرب
الاراضي والعمق الروسي ماذا في خلفيه مثل
هكذا تصريح
ان يكون هنا
ارحب بضيف
اعتقد ان هذا يوضح انه عندما يتعلق الامر
فيما يتعلق بطائرات
اف 16 واي انظمه
عسكريه لا تغير سياسه الولايات المتحده من
كونها تمنع منع استخدام الاسلحه
لمهاجمه روسيا في حدود داخل روسيا
اذا يمكن ان يكون لها استخدام ايجابي في
الهجمات المرتده الاوكرانيه بحسب الوقت
اللازمه لوصول تلك الطائرات وعلى المدى
الطويل يمكن ان تكون لها دور ولكن ما
يقوله سلفا انها لا تغير سياسه الولايات
المتحده في عدم السماح باستخدام الاسلحه
لمهاجمه روسيا داخل اراضي روسيا لكن كيف
يمكن ان تضمن ذلك الولايات المتحده السيد
مايكل وهل فقط الاكتفاء بالتعهدات
الاوكرانيه بعدم توجيه تلك الاسلحه باتجاه
الاراضي الروسيه كافل
اعتقد انه انويه المتحده هي شريك اساسي
لاوكرانيا ليس فقط فيما يتعلق بالاسلحه
ولكن التي قد توزدها تزودها بها في
المستقبل ومن قطع غيار وغيرها ولو ان
الاوكرانيين خلفوا هذه
الشروط فان ذلك
ربما لا يحظون بدعم امريكيين في المستقبل
اذا هناك خطوات عمليه يمكنها ان تحدث في
حال تم انتهاك هذا الاتفاق
سيد
مع الحديث الان عن تحول يعني موضوع وقضيه
الاف 16 الى حقيقه كيف نتوقع ان يغير ذلك
في المعادله
الميدانيه بالنسبه لروسيا
اعتقد ان تسليم مقاتلات
اف 16
اعتقد ان هذه الخطوه
والملاحظات التي قمنا بها سوليفان فيما
يتعلق بعدم استخدامها
على الاراضي الروسيه هو كذبه نوعا ما لان
الولايات المتحده في الوقت الحاضر لا تريد
ان تهدد روسيا
لا كلمه المتحده سوف تعطي الضوء الاخضر
لاستخدام تلك الاسلحه على الاراضي الروسيه
والمشكله هي انهم من وجهه نظر الروسيه فان
شبه جديد القرم هي ارض روسيه واذا اعتبرت
ان روسيا ان القرن هي ارض الاوكرانيه
اعتقد اذا ان استخدام الاسلحه والصواريخ
وغيرها على هذه الاراضي سوف تكون هي
الخطوه القادمه في التصعيد
الخطوه القادمه في التصعيد من من قبل من
انت تقصد سيد يعني اليوم كانت هناك ثنائيه
في حديث سال بانها لن تسمح باستخدام تلك
الاسلحه باتجاه روسيا لكنها لا تقيد
استخدام اوكرانيا لتلك الاسلحه في اراض
اوكرانيه كما تراها الولايات المتحده في
القرن
اكرر ما قلته
نعم المشكله هو ان القرن
هي مناطق روسيه من وجهه نظر موسكو وهي
اراضي روسيه واستخدام مثل هذه الصواريخ او
الاسلحه لاستهداف هذه الاراضي ستكون
بمثابه تصعيد من وجهه النظر الروسيه
الان شكرا لكم
من موسكو المحلل السياسي والاستراتيجي ومن
مونتانا مايكل مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي
السابق